so we have this quote here and this is
from a forward in your book and this is
by Jay Roach
and I don't know if you want to read
part of it and we've only fit a portion
of it on the board here we have the rest
of it here sure most development execs
producers and even assistants you
encounter along the way are solid story
crafters and could directly or
indirectly become your collaborators and
co-creators if you would dot dot dot
just engage with them enthusiastically
as teammates rather than defensively as
critics and saboteurs
where does your mind go when you hear
that quote well it what what immediately
Pops to mind is
how many
stories I know of people who found a
property or found a script or found a
writer and latched on and like a dog
with a bone forced that thing into
existence right so
you know I could think of you think
about Gina Bailey and with Game of
Thrones or
um
I don't know
I don't know I feel like a lot of things
that I've done where you find somebody
and you just go I'm so excited about
this writer you know let's figure it out
um there's a lot of stories I think that
you can
you can pull out of that HBO alone like
I said I'm listening to this book right
now and it's just like
you know David Levine and True Detective
like there's Franny orsi in um and how
she
really took I don't know she she took my
brilliant friend and just it was her
baby from start to finish now
that wasn't on anybody's radar
so
what a what a miracle that that she was
able to create something along with the
team that she had assembled and the
writer and and all of that into
something that's so beautiful so
you have to remember that for every
failed project there's probably another
you know equally passionate executive
who is putting together something else
and sometimes sometimes that thing that
first thing isn't the thing sometimes
it's the second thing sometimes it's the
third thing sometimes you just have to
keep going until you find the right
collaborator or you find that right idea
and it's the right time
you know there's so many again so many
pieces of why something works at a
particular time and why something might
just miss the mark but
we are all part of the same ecosystem
the executives the person who who
essentially takes that
piece of work
that writer
nurtures that writer
hopefully in the right way and then
gives that
that projects the
the the place to flourish into
and to grow and I think that
no one gets into being an executive with
terrible intentions we don't it's a lot
of work
so we don't go into it thinking I'm
going to go smash people's dreams and
ruin their careers you go in thinking
you can help you go in thinking oh I
love this writer so much I love this
idea so much
let me see how I can help it navigate
through the gauntlet of everything that
it needs to in order to
get to the finish line
and again I think that the when it when
things really hit they're usually
surprise
you know I think sometimes you can see
things coming I think when we all saw
the pilot of er we knew it was
groundbreaking or CSI the first one was
groundbreaking or you know there are
some pieces that just pop out you know
Breaking Bad they just think that that
just sort of automatically blow your you
know your hair back but
um sometimes things like Seinfeld that
take time to nurture and then become
huge and hit and hit really well
and you just don't know you just have to
believe in love in the the process and
the
the creators and
and you have to love story we just we
get into it because we love story we we
are the same people that you know look
I'm the perfect example I'm both writer
and executive and they had the ability
to to to do both and now I'm able to do
both
but I was the same person who watched
the 330 ABC movie you know every single
day and watched Fred Astaire and Ginger
Rogers and Annette and Frankie and
I wanted to be involved in that
storytelling and we all read a ton of
books and we all do our homework
and so our intentions are always good
we don't always execute them well and we
sometimes do have to grow up so I think
back on the the notes that I gave when I
was young they would be so different
today and I desperately feel like I want
to apologize to every writer I gave
notes to when I was too young to know
how it really really works
so sometimes we are not quite as skilled
as we want to be
and we need to do growing up just like a
writer needs to evolve just like the
whole process needs to evolve so
um but I think that he's absolutely
right in that
um we're all part of the same
big idea which is we all want to see
stories created and some of us just do
it on different sides of the
of the pro of the process
but we are all collaborators
sure but then when someone looks at it
in a defensive light
is it because you know you had said
earlier there's so much going on behind
the scenes that we don't always know
with the network and and whether it's
advertisers or or notes that the fans
are giving back different things and so
is the writer privy to all that not
always
I think there are a lot of you know
there are a lot of meetings that happen
and there's then there's sometimes
there's things that
that you hold back or you don't want to
I mean there's plenty of stories about I
have tons of stories about
projects that you'd be shocked about all
this the steps and the things and how
many times it might have fallen apart is
that important for the Creator to know
absolutely not would it hurt that
person's feelings absolutely if they
knew exactly what was happening in those
rooms it would be devastating
so sometimes that not knowing is not a
bad thing sometimes that's why people
feel like sometimes executives are too
close to the chest and because things
are they change the snap of a finger
so let's just say you've we've got a
project it looks like it's going forward
but I can't necessarily tell you for for
sure it's going forward because I don't
know they might change
they might change the whole Direction
the minute before I you know if I pull
the trigger too fast and then they
decided not to do something
then
then you've then I've then I've blown
that conversation you've already gotten
your hopes up so there's a reason
sometimes why they feel really cagey
because they don't know
or they haven't been given the
authorization to pull the trigger
um
and a perfect example of that is
I can't say it's perfect but so um
yunetta Boone who passed away had had
done a show a pilot called one-on-one
for us
and and yet you we didn't see it on air
until a year after so she she was
waiting for the pickup the year before
she was at the party she was waiting for
that note for the for we were in New
York and she was waiting for the the
notice that she was going to be on stage
that next day I'm pretty sure that
that's how it went
and we ended up at the last minute not
picking that show up
so
that was devastating enough but imagine
if we had already said you're on stage
and then we told her two seconds before
she wasn't gonna be on stage
now the good news is we loved it so much
we picked it up the next year and the
show was off the races in this amazing
show
but sometimes we don't have all the
information
and then that comes across as kg
deceitful they're not you know sharing
why are they doing this you know they
just don't know
so it's
it's a such a terrible little swirl of
you know silence that sometimes can
permeate and that can feel
um
that the that the world is against you
it feels like the execs are against you
but then what you don't see is the same
exacts fighting for a project
you know fighting for the life of
something I had to fight to get I wasn't
allowed to pick up Malcolm in the Middle
at UPN but I fought to get it released
in a time when there was a Polish strict
policy that said we do not release
projects
so they can go on other networks and I
said we need to this needs to exist
somewhere now you don't see that in
books you don't see that in
I think I might have written put in my
book but there you don't you don't hear
those stories about how people do
champion
and try to nurture and try to Foster and
try to
help
why would there why would there be execs
in the room fighting against it so then
why is one team want it and one team
doesn't well things you know things like
scheduling come into it so let's just
say at a network you've got you've got a
huge board when we were doing our
programming
for
um for UPN or even for Fox they have
these gigantic boards and on these
boards there's their strips so on one
side it's like the the time slot and
then the network or either way time slot
in the network and then
uh each little strip it's a magnetized
strip has the name of the show that the
pilot that was just produced and so what
we're doing is we're hedging our bets
and we're trying to think well if CBS
has all procedurals and we're trying to
counter program with all comedies what's
the best comedy that goes up against the
sebrios procedural the drama family
drama on NBC the ABC's got you know uh
comedies but they're buddy comedies
let's go with a family comedy or let's
go with a drama so we are trying to
figure out our schedule based on what
other people are doing so at the time
that we're doing this this has been
again right up right before up fronts so
people haven't announced their schedules
when they get announced is when
everybody knows specifically when things
are happening
so we are trying to counter program and
figure out well what's our best slate
that's going to do well against the
others because we don't want as a UPN or
a or a fox or even if you're thinking
you know these days with with some of
the other networks they don't want the
same show to compete against the same
show right they don't want a black
female comedy up against another black
female comedy or cannibalize your
audience so we're trying to find the
spaces where those audiences are are not
being served someplace else
that's why sometimes things move forward
or don't move forward that's why
somebody might be fighting for for or
against maybe they don't love that show
or they don't love that star or they
don't think that it's going to do well
on for that particular demographic or
whatever there's so many different
reasons again those are that's making
the sausage that's the whole other thing
that's that's underneath that people
don't always hear about
you know do we have the Right audience
are people showing up to us for this
or can they get this better someplace
else